this is a site reliability engineer they
need to monitor cloud services and
respond to issues rapidly yet they
support a wide variety of platforms
architectures and infrastructure
requiring a broad skill set and so they
are hoping to use duet Ai and Google
Cloud to help them stay ahead of any
service disruptions let's observe this
SRE as they use duet AI to simplify the
task at hand Services launched in
production live traffic holidays nearing
winter is coming we know what that means
issues errors and downtime and of course
that's what this and every other srre
are prepared for responds to the worst
so the site app or service performs its
best based on the the alerts showing up
in this inbox they seem to be having
some issues with a cloud run service
time to dig in going into the incident
they are reviewing the metrics inside
Cloud console looking for a root cause
the errors have spiked but what else
could be going on here the prom ql query
shown here is generating this report but
we need to widen the scope to find out
if other services are impacted using
natural language and duet AI the SRE can
modify the query to see what other
services might be affected without
needing a refresher on Prometheus syntax
the SR now has an expanded view for this
project and they see now the impact on
other services profile login checkout
problem found but why has this happen
logs Explorer shows the errors and duet
AI can help explain what these details
mean giving an easy to digest summary of
the log entry Beyond explanation duet AI
can also help fix the issue at hand now
we've got instructions for how to follow
up and mitigate this error our SRE has
saved tons of time with root cause
analysis and troubleshooting leaving
them more time for practicing clarinet
what will you
build
[Music]
h